what I want to do in this video is talk
a little bit about maybe why the plates
are actually moving in the first place
and nothing I'm talking about this video
has been definitively proved this is
just kind of the current thinking the
leading thinking on why plates are
actually moving although we haven't seen
the definitive evidence yet and it's
probably a combination of a bunch of
things now before we even talk about
plates let's just talk about convection
and you might already be familiar with
the term but just in case you're not
let's do a little bit of review of
convection so let's say I have a pot
over here so that is my pot and it
contains some water so I have water in
my pot and I let's say I only heat one
end of the pot so I put a flame right
over at that end of the pot so what's
going to happen well the water the water
that's right over the flame is going to
be warmed up that more than any of the
other water so this water is going to
get is going to get warm but when it
gets warm it also becomes less dense
when you have a fluid if you warm it up
you're going to the molecules are
vibrating more they have more kinetic
energy they're going to bounce further
distances away from each other they will
become less dense and if you have
something that's less dense and it's
surrounded by things that are more dense
and we're dealing in kind of a fluid
state right here that warm less dense
water is going to move upwards is going
to move upwards well when it moves
upwards something has to replace it
something has to replace it so you're
going to have cooler water cooler water
from this side of the container kind of
replacing where that water was now this
water as it rises as this water rises
what's going to happen to it
what's going to cool down it's going to
get further from the flame it's going to
mix with maybe some of the other water
or some of the other water or transfer
some of it's a kinetic energy to the
neighboring water so it'll cool down but
once it cools down what's it we're going
to want to do remember in general the
closer you are to the flame so the water
closer to the flame in general is going
to be warmer so all of this stuff is
going to be warmer and all of this stuff
up here like the coldest water is always
going to be farthest from the flame and
so it's going to be the coldest
water is going to be over here but
remember the coldest water is also the
densest water so the dense so this water
over here is dense and so it will sink
it's denser than the water around it and
it also helps replace the water that's
going here to get warmed up again and so
what you do is you have the cycle here
warm water rises moves over to the right
down here and then goes back down as it
cools down and it's dense and then it
gets warmed up again and so this process
and this process essentially what it's
doing is it's it's transferring the heat
it's allowing the heat to be transferred
from this one spot throughout the fluid
and so we call this process this as this
is convection this is convection now the
reason why we think the plates are
moving is because we think that there
are similar types of convection cards in
the asthenosphere in the mantle in the
more in the more fluid part of the man
to remember the mantle most of the
mantle is kind of this you can kind of
view this mushy spongy not quite liquid
but not quite solid state kind of
plastic it can kind of kind of mush past
it can kind of flow like super super
super thick you know I guess you could
call them you know like well like super
viscous fluid so not quite solid not
quite liquid but the same thing could be
happening you have certain areas in the
mantle that are hotter than others in
this particular in the asthenosphere and
those areas that's where you're going to
have that's where you're going to have
the material in the mantle move up
because it's hotter it's less dense and
it will move up and maybe it'll cause
one of these divergent rifts where
content where where kind of plate
material and crustal material is forming
and then as it moves up it cools down it
cools down it cools down and eventually
sinks and eventually sinks only to get
heated up again so it has these kind of
circular motion just like we saw with
the boiling water and so that process
remember this isn't this isn't
completely liquid so it is rocky so it's
going to it's going to potentially be
able to take other things with it it
could maybe drag the crust
along with it and that would cause that
or I should say it could drag the
lithosphere along with it not just the
crust it could drag all this rigid rock
up here along with it causing it to move
causing it to move in that general
direction so you have the drag there you
could also imagine that just kind of a
suction effect where if you view it as a
fluid you have a bunch of fluid coming
down here so it kind of pull the
lithosphere down at those points and
would kind of push the lithosphere up it
would push the lid the sphere up at
those points so you have these
convection currents you have these
convection currents that are essentially
that are essentially driving and you
know these aren't going to be super fast
moving fluid convection currents like
you would expect with boiling water or
with heated water these would be
slow-moving convection currents but
they're moving they're moving enough and
they're able to kind of put enough drag
on the lithosphere to take the
lithosphere along with it and so that's
kind of at a high level the dominant
theory as to why they're moving there's
other ones that talk about you know
maybe these these these the lithospheric
plates there's their cut they're kind of
they thicken as they move further away
from this these this area where the
ridge is forming and if we look at this
oceanic crust right over here and so
over time there's kind of their denser
over here because there's more there's
more cooldown material at these points
and so and that's it's already a little
bit lower because this is where a lot of
the land is being created and so there's
maybe some gravitational effects but the
dominant effect we think is due to this
convection in the upper mantle